thomas pesquet ses coéquipiers et devait
revenir sur terre aujourd'hui c'est un
retour finalement repoussée à demain
matin en raison de mauvaises conditions
météorologiques à thomas bès qui aura à
passer six mois dans l'espace il a remis
les clés de la station spatiale
internationale à son nouveau commandant
de cosmonautes russes anton chkaplerov
on en parle avec un autre correspondant
depuis moscou vera kaufmann les clés de
la station spatiale internationale sont
désormais entre les mains du cosmonaute
russe anton chkaplerov la cérémonie
officielle une formalité symbolique a eu
lieu ce samedi à bord de la station
spatiale internationale
l'astronaute de l'agencé spatiale
européenne thomas pesquet qui était de
commandes de l' iss depuis le 4 octobre
2020 s'apprête lui à revenir sur terre
avec l'équipage de la mission de crue
dragon's den comme le veut la tradition
la cérémonie de passation de pouvoir
s'est conclue au sens d'une cloche donne
à lire les deux spationautes russes et
français ont exprimé beaucoup d'estimé
l'un pour l'autre je vous propose
d'écouter
je ne peux exprimer à quel point je suis
reconnaissant de tout le travail réalisé
par tant de personnes à travers le monde
pour permettre à un si petit groupe de
venir dans l'espace pour le bénéfice de
tous
je suis très fier d'être le commandant
de cette expédition
nous allons réaliser de nombreuses
expériences spatiales et je sais que
nous allons vivre une expédition très
intéressante à bord
anton chkaplerov est arrivé sur les ss
le 5 octobre dernier accompagné de
l'équipe de tournage du film décide du
les pires il est clean shipping co qui
ont travaillé pendant douze jours en
orbite sur le premier long métrage
tourné dans l'espace à pau en tant
qu'appelé rohff âgé de 49 ans il s'agit
de la quatrième mission sur les ss
dupuis 2011 pilote de formation elle a
suivi le cursus d'ingénieur explorateurs
puis deux cosmonautes c'est aujourd'hui
l'un des cosmonautes russes les plus
expérimentés avec à son actif cinq cent
trente deux jours en orbite et 14h28
dans l'espace ouvert je capte les roms
va maintenant diriger la station
spatiale internationale jusqu'à son
retour sur terre prévu pour le printemps